[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend
viele blicken ja derzeit us-versorger
auf den winter wie wird das werden mit
der gasversorgung werden wir die wohnung
heizen können doch bevor es ans frieren
geht steht uns erst mal noch eine neue
hitzewelle bevor die in europa
einschließlich deutschland nächste woche
so extrem werden könnte dass sie vor
allem für alte und kranke
lebensgefährlich ist solche hitzewellen
sind aber nur eine seite der medaille
daneben haben wir wieder einen zu
trockenen sommer und hatten in teilen
europas auch schon einen zu trockenen
frühling und schneearmen winter so
fehlte es schon an schnells wasser das
die flüsse fühlt füllt deshalb ist in
italien die poebene jetzt praktisch
ausgedockt lara wieder kind zeigt welche
folgen die dürre in deutschland hat
die trockenheit sieht man nicht sofort
im kleingartenverein tiefe wiese wachsen
gemüse und blumen ein grünes paradies
haben jutta dräger und ihr mann sich
hier geschaffen heute gehen sie im
verein sparsam mit dem wasser um das war
früher nicht so da wurde der springer
hingestellt und dann gewinn was der
wasserhahn er gab dann da hat eben keine
rücksicht darauf genommen dass da der
auch unsinnig teilweise ist denn wenn
ich gucke kartoffeln kartoffeln ruiz
blatt nicht nass machen kartoffeln kann
ich mir reden ziehen und das wasser in
die rillen laufen lassen südlich von
magdeburg hat es geregnet auf dem acker
von landwirt eckhard herrmann ist es
etwas matschig doch das problem liegt
tiefer
hier merkt man schon dass der boden wie
oft viele viele feste und trockener wird
nicht nur der juni war zu trocken seit
2008 zehn regnet es nicht genug in der
region ist der pegelstand um ungefähr
zwei meter abgesagt so hamann
das ist insofern für die pflanzen
tragisch weil sie eben nicht nur 20
zentimeter tief wurzeln sondern bei
weizen zb auch bis zu einem meter
achtzig tief wurzeln wasser herkriegen
und auch nährstoffe herkriegen doch wo
nichts ist können die pflanzen sich
nicht erholen eine folge sie reifen
früher ab die erträge sinken die
landschaft sei unser größter
wasserspeicher sagt dr carsten rinke vom
helmholtz zentrum für umweltforschung
keine tags wäre könne sie ersetzen dabei
sind versiegelte flächen ein großes
problem wir müssen dafür sorgen dass ein
größerer anteil unserer niederschläge
versickert und den weg durch den boden
und das grundwasser nimmt und eben nicht
wie im moment relativ schnell abgeleitet
wird und dann relativ schnell im
fließgewässer landet und daneben neun
tage später im meer ist und weg die
trockenheit zwingt auch meter hohe
eichen und nadelbäume in die knie sie
werden anfälliger für schädlinge und
krankheiten und dieser trockenstress
halt nach
erfahrungsgemäß ist es so dass die
trockenschäden bei den älteren waldböden
eine sehr langfristige
wirkung haben und
davon auszugehen ist dass ich wenige
davon selbst wenn die niederschlags
situation eine bessere wieder wird von
dieser schädigungen erholen werden die
dürre betrifft große teile deutschlands
der ausbleibende regen seit teil der
natürlichen wetterschwankungen doch der
menschengemachte klimawandel verschärft
die situation
natürlich gibt es auch im natürlichen
klima trockenphasen und und feuchte
phasen aber was sich eben geändert hat
und was sich aufgrund des klimawandels
auch weiterhin dramatisch ändern wird
ist das eben unsere sommer viel heißer
sind jetzt schon als ohne klimawandel
gewesen wären und diese hitze sorge
dafür dass der regen schneller
verdunstet das wasser weniger lang
vorhält im landkreis stendal ist es
verboten tagsüber zu bewässern eine
richtige entscheidung findet die
kleingärtnerin jutta träger in zeiten
der trockenheit
tja und unser meteorologe ersten terry
ist bei uns im studio ist dann diese
angekündigte hitzewelle nächste woche
was erwartet uns da ja da kommt heiße
luft aus dem süden erst einmal und zwar
aus der richtung aus spanien in richtung
frankreich und das ist die erste welle
muss man sagen die er bis mitte der
woche etwa 35 grad bringt und dann
richtung wochenende wird es dann noch
heißer und dann eben diese temperaturen
die durchaus extrem werden können 40
grad und mehr dann durch drin sind das
muss man natürlich dann abwarten können
jemals schauen wie sich das entwickelt
also 35 grad etwa bis mittwoch man sieht
im norden ist es nicht ganz so heiß wie
im südwesten zum beispiel und hier noch
mal ein beispiel zum beispiel für köln
da haben wir 40 grad wir haben immer die
moderaten temperaturen genommen es gibt
modelle die durchaus mehr hergeben aber
das muss man wirklich abwarten weil bis
nächste woche ist ja noch einiges an
zeit also 40 grad es ja auch schon
heftig gut so eine hitzewelle gibt es im
sommer immer wieder mal oder ist das
doch ungewöhnlich also hitzewellen neben
generell zu mit der klimakrise mit der
erhitzung der temperatur da ist sich die
wissenschaft einig und wir können mal
schauen wir haben hier für deutschland
eine grafik wo quasi die hitzetage
aufgezeichnet sind und die nehmen
einfach zu im laufe der jahrzehnte sind
sie immer mehr geworden und ja das ist
eine klare entwicklung hitzewellen
nebenan länge zu an intensität und an
häufigkeit also dass es ein ganz klarer
hinweis darauf dass die erhitzung in
deutschland sich weiter
fortführt quasi und die projektionen des
deutschen wetterdienstes sagen auch bis
ende des jahrzehntes ganz klar die
temperaturen in deutschland steigen
weiter an und somit die gefahr von
extremwetterereignissen
dankeschön ersten teil gerne
häufigere und längere dürreperioden
führen natürlich auch weltweit zu
einbrüchen bei der ernte und gefährden
die lebensmittelversorgung
hinzu kommt dass hunger als
machtinstrument missbraucht wird der
krieg in der ukraine verhindert nicht
nur die ausfuhr von getreide nach afrika
und in den nahen osten den russen wird
außerdem vorgeworfen dass die
getreidevorräte stehlen und gezielt
felder in brand setzten doch nicht nur
in der ukraine führt russland mit
lebensmitteln krieg auch in syrien
russland hat jetzt dafür gesorgt dass in
den rebellengebieten im nordwesten
syriens der letzte hilfs korridor wohl
geschlossen wird das un-mandat das
humanitäre lieferungen über die türkisch
syrischen grenze dorthin ermöglichte
läuft heute nacht aus eine verlängerung
hat russland im un sicherheitsrat
bislang blockiert brücke sa berichtet
auch jetzt schon reicht es oft kaum zum
leben hat ihn ist witwe zusammen mit
ihren enkelkindern haus ziehen einem
flüchtlingslager im umland von aleppo
sie hat kein eigenes einkommen wie
millionen vertriebene in der region ist
sie darauf angewiesen dass hilfsgüter
über den ball haut grenzübergang kommen
wenn die grenze schließt wird das ein
desaster für uns für alle hier dann wird
es überall kämpfe ums essen geben
auch das lan der lagerverwalter ist im
krieg vor den truppen asads geflohen mit
großer sorge hat er vom vorschlag
russlands im sicherheitsrat erfahren
alle hilfsgüter künftig in die
hauptstadt zu liefern und von dort unter
der kontrolle ersatz verteilen zu lassen
dann würde viel weniger hier ankommen
das wäre eine humanitäre katastrophe
es ist hoch kritisch den regime die
kontrolle über die hilfsgüter zu geben
das ist für uns ein schlag ins gesicht
dazu kommt dass auch regionale
lebensmittel immer teurer werden
ahmed ist landwirt in der region aleppo
erbaut weizen mais und gemüse an die
diesjährige ernte ist schlecht es gab
hagelstürme und vor allem zu wenig regen
mit kunstdünger und spritbetriebenen
wasserpumpen versucht er das
auszugleichen
wir ernten nur etwa die hälfte während
die kosten explodieren der krieg
zwischen russland und der ukraine macht
mich nur den dünger sehr viel teurer
hunger und mangelernährung greifen
weiter um sich in der region gerade bei
den jüngsten denn auch die lieferung von
babynahrung steht auf dem spiel ihre not
scheint nun unterzugehen im politischen
streit um die versorgungswege für
hilfsgüter
wir können nur hoffen dass sie
alternativen finden wenn die grenze zu
ist wir haben hier tausende kinder
frauen und variable gruppen deren leben
davon abhängt
die zukunft der menschen im nordwesten
syriens ist mehr denn je ungewiss denn
russland im un sicherheitsrat nicht doch
noch einlenkt endet dieses wochenende
die resolution die den grenzübergang
ball für hilfsgüter offen gehalten hat
dann bricht dort die letzte rote für
unabhängige humanitäre hilfe weg
derweil geht auch der krieg in der
ukraine weiter und die russische
propaganda nimmt immer schrillere züge
man muss übrigens nicht russisch können
um sich dass man selbst anzusehen was da
im russischen fernsehen geboten wird auf
twitter beispielsweise gibt es die
regelmäßig ein best of mit untertiteln
zusammenstellen und da kann einem dann
teils schon der mund offen stehen
bleiben was putzens sprachrohre so alles
von sich geben zwei moderatoren tun sich
besonders hervor margaritas simonyan
chefredakteurin der propaganda kanäle rt
und sputnik die nicht müde wird der
ukraine jedes existenzrecht abzusprechen
und vladimir soll wie oft er schon mal
dazu aufrief deutschland möglichst bald
an zu greifen solange die bundeswehr
noch schwach seien
kristiansand berichtet
fast jeden abend präsentiert wladimir
solowjow einer von putins prominentesten
scharfmachern im staats-tv seine große
propaganda show da wird zum beispiel
deutschland offen mit krieg gedroht
westliche politiker werden beschimpft
und an den pranger gestellt in dieser
sendung ist eu kommissionspräsident in
ursula von der leyen dran von der leyen
spricht über europäische werte und dass
die ukraine den krieg gewinnen soll dann
kommt zur lobby mit einem nazi-vergleich
da fehlt nur noch ein sieg heil und die
hacken zusammenschlagen so der moderator
er sagt ursula begreifst du welchen
unsinn du redest und er wendet sich an
deutschland zuständig ihr seid es
gewohnt dass dem deutschen reich der
kleine bruder dient das ukrainische
reich wanderer ist ein treuer nachahmer
des führers der deutschen nationalelf
hitler
was macht das mit den russinnen und
russen wenn den ganzen tag im fernsehen
nur propaganda und hetze laufen dieser
herr prophezeit unserem russischen
mitarbeiter eine schwierige zukunft wenn
er so weitermacht dann deutschen
fernsehen die offene drohung aber nicht
alle folgen dieser propaganda
alles krasse lügen ich weiß nicht ob er
das selbst glaubt es ist schwer so läuft
überhaupt einen journalisten zu nennen
meiner erfahrung nach informieren sich
die leute eher über youtube und
telegramm und die ältere generation
kupfer
den ganzen tag flimmern die immer
gleichen botschaften über die
staatskapelle der westen sei verkommen
mit seinen unfähigen politikern und fade
medien das liberale gesellschaftsmodell
in europa und den usa sei gescheitert
die frierenden deutschen die sich mit
den sanktionen vor allem selbst schaden
putins informations truppen sind die
hauptstütze des regimes wichtiger als
die strukturen der rechtsschutz und
sicherheitsorgane die propaganda
gewährleistet die loyalität der
bevölkerung sie sicher das hinterland ab
das ist das wichtigste kritik wird
unterdrückt wer das russische militär in
augen des kremls öffentlich
diskreditiert kann im gefängnis landen
am freitag erst wurde der moskauer
lokalpolitiker alexej gori noch zu
sieben jahren haft verurteilt weil er
die russische militär operation in einer
ratssitzung als krieg bezeichnet braucht
ihr diesen krieg noch fragt der an
tuberkulose erkrankte chorin auf diesem
zettel noch bei seiner verurteilung
applaus seiner familie und anhänger er
will nichts zurücknehmen und der 60
jährige fügt noch hinzu sie haben mir
den frühling genommen sie haben mir den
sommer genommen und jetzt haben sie mir
sieben jahre meines lebens genommen
für begannen moskau kritiker werden
weggesperrt während die propagandisten
immer schriller werden und das ist ja
für unsere augen und ohren schon
geradezu bizarr wie wie sehr ist diese
propaganda eigentlich auch nach außen
gerüchte um dem westen um uns angst zu
machen
also diese russischen talkshows die sind
meiner einschätzung nach schon an ein
heimisches publikum gerichtet da geht es
darum das russische volk in einer art
alarm zustand zu versetzen damit gar
niemand erst auf die idee kommt
vielleicht mal was kritisch zu
hinterfragen oder gar zu widersprechen
und damit dieser alarm zustand sich
nicht abnutzt müssen die sendungen eben
immer deftigere töne anschlagen und
immer krassere bedrohungsszenarien an
die wand malen dass das bei einem
publikum in einem demokratischen land
nicht so verfangen würde das dürfte den
programmmachern durchaus klar sein und
dafür also für die desinformation im
westen und auch um die botschaften der
russischen tief im westen zu verbreiten
hat russland ja nochmal ganz eigene
instrumente und kanäle die tatsache dass
das budget der staatsmedien und dazu
zählt eben zum beispiel auch der
auslandssender rt seit beginn der
militäroffensive verdreifacht wurde das
zeigt doch wie wichtig die medien im
dafür sind dass präsident putin seine
ziele erreicht man muss putin davon
abgesehen ein interesse daran haben dass
die bevölkerung vor allem moskau und
sankt petersburg von dem was er
spezialoperation nennt im alter
möglichst im alltag möglichst wenig
mitbekommt gelingt das
eigentlich nur bedingt muss man sagen
denn einerseits ist es schon so dass die
meisten soldaten und damit auch die
meisten gefallenen aus den regionen
russlands kommen und dass die wut und
die trauer dem auch möglicherweise in
protest umschlagen können sich vor allem
abseits der metropolen abspielt aber die
ersten auswirkungen der sanktionen die
sind hier in moskau oder in sankt
petersburg auch in den anderen
millionenstädten russlands eigentlich
deutlicher zu spüren denn hier leben die
menschen die sich in den letzten jahren
und jahrzehnten an urlaubsreisen ins
ausland an amerikanische smartphones
oder auch an deutsche autos gewöhnt
haben und jetzt auf diese
annehmlichkeiten verzichten müssen oder
sehr viel mehr dafür bezahlen müssen der
moskauer bürgermeister geht übrigens
davon aus dass in den nächsten monaten
250.000 moskauer innen ihre jobs
verlieren werden wegen des abzugs
westlicher firmen aus der stadt und den
anderen metropolen wird es sicherlich
ganz ähnlich aussehen die einschätzung
so russland korrespondentin dankeschön
filme nach moskau mit dem krieg und
seinen folgen gibt es jetzt auch in den
nachrichten noch weiter heinz und zwar
mit den russischen gas lieferungen über
die pipeline nord stream 1 die
kanadische regierung will nun trotz der
sanktionen eine turbine für die pipeline
freigeben die dort gewartet wurde
russland hatte den gasfluss durch nord
stream 1 gedrosselt unter anderem mit
der begründung dass diese turbine fehle
wie es mit der gaslieferung durch diese
pipeline weiter geht es auch eines der
themen in unserem ausblick am ende der
sendung
sollte energie in deutschland knapp und
noch teurer werden will
verbraucherschutzministerin lemke kunden
davor schützen dass ihnen strom oder gas
abgestellt wird sollten sie ihre
rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlen können
sie sagte der bild am sonntag im
krisenfall müsste man auch über ein
weiteres hilfspaket entscheiden
die russischen streitkräfte haben ihre
angriffe im osten der ukraine
fortgesetzt und dort vor allem in der
region donetsk im ort chassis fia in
dieser region sind bei einem russischen
raketen angriffe auf ein wohnhaus nach
ukrainischen angaben mindestens 15
menschen getötet worden mehr als 20
weitere seien vermutlich noch unter den
trümmern verschüttet
nach wahlniederlagen sexismus skandal
und führungskrise bei der partei die
linke will ihr ko-vorsitzender
schirdewahn die partei aus der
dauerkrise holen im zdf-sommerinterview
erklärte er das land befindet sich in
einer existenziellen krise und brauche
endlich wieder eine starke linke die der
regierung auf die füße treten deshalb
konzentriere sich die partei auf das
ziel tatsächlich wieder erkennbarer in
der öffentlichkeit in erscheinung zu
treten ich erwarte dass die führenden
politikerinnen und politiker meiner
partei die position die wir miteinander
demokratisch verhandeln und bestimmen
auch nach außen hin vertreten ja und das
ganze interview finden sie online unter
heute.de
in sri lanka ist nach den angekündigten
rücktritten von präsident und premier
wieder ruhe eingekehrt und der
hauptstadt colombo halten die menschen
den präsidentenpalast besetzt und
erkunden friedlich welche
annehmlichkeiten er zu bieten hat
gestern waren mehr als 100.000 menschen
auf die straße gegangen aus protest
gegen die bisher schlimmste
wirtschaftskrise und eine korrupte
regierung sie fordern jetzt eine
komplett neue regierung
auf ihrer asien reise machte annalena
baerbock heute station in japan das land
steht nach der ermordung des früheren
premierministers shinzo abe noch unter
schock zu einer eher gedrückten stimmung
dürfte aber auch der besuch der
ministerin in nagasaki beitragen die
sich dort das museum an dass an den
abwurf der us-atombomben
1945 erinnert
das passt in eine zeit in der mit
russland eine nuklearmacht austestet wie
weit sie gehen kann und ob der westen
sich ihrer invasion entgegenstellt in
ostasien wird das aufmerksam verfolgt
schließlich gibt es hier mit china
ebenfalls eine atommacht die expansiven
appetit zeigt den treibern fürchten
viele dass ihnen ein ähnliches schicksal
droht wie der ukraine miriam stein
berichtet
es sieht aus wie ein videospiel doch es
ist üben für den ernstfall
seit ein paar wochen trainiert julian
hier vorher hatte er die eine waffe in
der hand eigentlich handelt er mit
fitnessgeräten
ich hätte überhaupt keine ahnung von
waffen und wollte etwas lernen damit ich
im falle eines krieges helfen kann
der auslöser für seinen wunsch russlands
angriff auf die ukraine der hat auf
taiwan die angst von vielen verstärkt
dass china diesem vorbild folgen könnte
ich bin sehr besorgt über den krieg in
der ukraine in den nachrichten habe ich
gesehen wie effektiv der widerstand dort
ist wenn wir alle an einem strang ziehen
haben wir wohl eine chance also bin ich
gekommen um zu lernen bis zu viermal
mehr leute kommen seitdem zu diesem
trainingsplatz in einem vorort der
hauptstadt taipeh für schießtraining
selbstverteidigung oder erste hilfe
leute mit militär oder polizei
hintergrund aber auch die damit bisher
gar nichts zu tun hatten auch immer mehr
frauen
auch china trainiert mit manövern in der
umgebung von taiwan lässt das militär
immer wieder die muskeln spielen und übt
schon mal die wiedervereinigung so nennt
es der chinesische präsident hu für ihn
ist die demokratische insel kisch
territorium sein ziel den abtrünnigen
bruder zurückholen
mit großer inszenierung weite sein land
vor kurzem seinen dritten flugzeugträger
ein putin heißt er bezeichnenderweise
ist dass der name der chinesischen
provinz die direkt gegenüber von taiwan
liegt
diese bilder haben auch tätowierer zu
tun dazu gebracht sich auf einen
möglichen angriff chinas vorzubereiten
und statt seiner nadel immer mal wieder
ein luftgewehr in den händen zu halten
klar die meisten menschen wollen nicht
in den krieg ziehen ich auch nicht aber
für den unglücklichen fall dass es
wirklich dazu kommt werde ich mental
vorbereitet sein
nicht nur private trainiert auch die
regierung will die militärischen
fähigkeiten stärken die auf vier monate
verkürzte wehrpflicht könnte wieder
verlängert werden und das halten hier
viele für eine gute idee und üben weiter
für den ernstfall
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit dem sport
zunächst zur formel 1 heute großer preis
von österreich sieger beim rennen in
spielberg wurde schale claire vor max
verstappen und lewis hamilton und mit
schumacher fuhr erneut in die punkte mit
mutigen überholmanövern wie hier ein
kevin magnussen hat er sich das redlich
verdient rang sechs und gewählter fahrer
des tages
zeigen hoffentlich dann auch in der
zukunft
nach mehreren haben noch so viele punkte
sammeln kann max für staaten gewinn zwar
den staat muss sich aber danach dem
stärkeren ferrari von charlie klar
geschlagen geben aufregung kurz vor
schluss carlos sainz sind steigt in
letzter sekunde unverletzt seinem wegen
motorschadens brennenden ferrari
und jetzt zum tennis und zu einem
weiteren titelgewinn für in wimbledon
für novak djokovic
er gewann das finale gegen piräus in
vier sätzen novak djokovic ser könig in
seinem englischen garten der serbe
gewinnt zum siebten mal auf wimbledons
rasen auch weil sich eine kirche aus
australien mit seiner verbalen rebellion
oftmals selbst außer gefecht setzt nach
verlorenem ersten satz kämpfte sich
djokovic in die partie zurück und
nutzt im tie break des vierten satzes
seinen dritten matchball sein 21
grand-slam-titel ein ganz besonderer
es war immer und wird immer mein herzens
turnier sein die inspiration für mich
warum ich tennis spiele
der siegerpokal aus den händen von
herzogin kate mal wieder eine art
krönung für novak djokovic
die größte gefahr gehe heute vom
rechtsterrorismus aus sagt der
verfassungsschutz die erkenntnis hatte
er lange zeit nicht dass die
sicherheitsbehörden auf dem rechten auge
blind waren dafür haben
extremismusforscher auch
zeitgeschichtliche erklärungen so sei
die vorstellung von terrorismus in
westdeutschland von der raf geprägt
gewesen eine gruppe die sich zu erkennen
gab und staatsziele angriff rechts
terroristen gingen anders vor schon
lange vorm nsu man denke nur an den
anschlag aufs oktoberfest
1980 zu einer zeit als der staat noch
ganz auf den links terror fixiert war
ein relikt dieser deutschen geschichte
wird nun im wahrsten sinne des wortes
auf dem müllhaufen geworfen der
berühmt-berüchtigte gerichtssaal in
stammheim wird abgerissen eva schiller
und jasmina stucky buddy berichten
er nennt den saal sein arbeitszimmer als
junger staatsanwalt vertritt klaus
pflieger in 19 f prozessen die anklage
von den linksterroristen beschimpft
beleidigt bedroht führen richter und
staatsanwälte strichlisten für jeden
verhandlungstag
wir haben uns wie häftlinge in diesem
prozess saal villiger diese situationen
zu belasten würden das war eine
konfrontation die der staat so noch
nicht erlebt hat vor 50 jahren werden
die anführer der roten armee fraktion
verhaftet für den prozess bringt man
ulrike meinhof gudrun ensslin carl raspe
und andreas baader in das damals
modernste hochsicherheits gefängnis
stuttgart stammheim
auch nicht wieso sich die
bundesregierung erst mal das ausgedacht
habt das zubauen im gerichtssaal hat
eigentlich dazu geführt dass eine
bedeutung zu geben die sie politisch
eigentlich nicht hatte mord und
versuchter mord in 54 fällen so lautet
die anklage
wie groß der druck auf die justiz ist
zeigt sich an nie dagewesenen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
und fragwürdigen methoden zum beispiel
werden die raf anwälten abgehört die
angeklagten isoliert der wankende
rechtsstaat hilft den tätern sich als
opfer zu inszenieren das ist folter
exakt folter
mit der erzählung opfer eines
repressiven staates zu sein also diese
erzählung hat sich eben als eine
unglaublich erfolgreiche
propagandistische strategie erwiesen für
autorin bettina röhl ist stammheim das
grabmal ihrer mutter ulrike meinhof wird
1976 erhängt in ihrer zelle gefunden mit
13 war es natürlich ein ziemlicher
schock
also und ein riesiger der größtmögliche
schock überhaupt und es war ja gar kein
privates ereignis es war ein politisches
ereignis die die welt sich in zwei lager
die einen sagte sein mord und die andere
seite es war selbstmord
die erst jahre später erwiesenen
selbstmorde der restlichen führungsriege
befeuern den opfermythos weiter weil
offene fragen bleiben wusste der staat
von den geplanten suiziden wurden die
inhaftierten abgehört auch in jener
nacht jetzt wäre es wirklich höchste
zeit aus meiner sicht diesen letzten
nebel des deutschen herbstes noch zu
vertreiben also der staat müsste ganz
dringend die akten offen legen die eben
auch illegale staatliche praktiken
dokumentieren wir können nur dazulernen
wenn du selbst kritisch sind und auch
vorstellen das war falsch und das muss
man anderes das muss man besser machen
es ist eigentlich schade dass man so ein
gebäude auf gibt da so symbolträchtig
ist das inventar des
hochsicherheitstrakt landet auf dem müll
für die einen geht ein stück deutsche
geschichte verloren für die andern endet
mit stammheim ein mythos der täter statt
opfer in den vordergrund rückt und
jetzt noch unser sonntägliche ausblick
auf die nächste woche den hat luisa
ruben für uns zusammen gestellt
[Musik]
ab montag soll die gaspipeline nord
stream 1 gewartet werden dass es lange
geplant und soll zehn tage dauern gas
wird währenddessen nicht fließen ob
russland den gashahn danach wieder
öffnen wird ist ungewiss
die welthungerhilfe will am dienstag
ihren neuesten jahresbericht vorstellen
er soll antworten geben auf die frage
welche folgen die klimakrise vertreibung
und flucht auf die weltweite
lebensmittelversorgung haben
us präsident biden plant am mittwoch in
den nahen osten zu reisen auch nach
saudi arabien
dafür erntet er kritik denn beiden hat
vor kronprinz salman zu treffen dieser
soll laut us geheimdiensten
mitverantwortlich sein für den mord an
journalisten kaschau am
donnerstag ist die flutkatastrophe ein
jahr her im aartal und teilen von
nordrhein-westfalen verloren menschen
ihr zuhause mehr als 100 starben
vielerorts werden gedenk veranstaltungen
stattfinden
und auch die wetteraussichten zum start
in die neue woche morgen gibt es in
einem streifen von der nordsee bis zum
bayerischen wald viele wolken es regnet
aber kaum sonst scheint oft die sonne
die temperatur steigt auf 18 bis 23 im
südwesten bis 28 grad und am anfang der
sendung war schon angesprochen die
kommenden tage bringen hochsommerliches
wetter zwar mit einigen wolken aber auch
viel sonne und höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 19 und 35 grad
das was von uns gleich gehts weiter mit
dem sonntags training oder 0 25 gibt es
die nächste express es morgen wieder
sehen
[Musik]